[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend verbringen sie so kurz vor
dem fest wie gewohnt auf den stand der
dinge tun das natürlich auch sportlich
heute wieder mit kristin otto noch heute
sehr gern genannt und das sind unsere
themen
hoffnung auf milderen verlauf omikron
ist offenbar weniger gefährlich als die
delta variante sagen britische studien
das rk ii meldet den ersten omikron
toten in deutschland
putin fordert sicherheitsgarantien
russlands präsident bestreitet eine
invasion der ukraine vorzubereiten und
wirft der nato eine massive erweiterung
nach osten vor
weihnachten im container einige opfer
der flutkatastrophe im aartal können
rechtzeitig zum fest in ihren heimatort
zurück
zum weihnachtsfest und ende des jahres
müssen wir uns also wieder
zusammenreißen und auf unsere kontakte
achten die korona variante omikron ist
weiter auf dem vormarsch und wie rasant
sich die mutanten bei uns verbreitet
teilte heute das robert koch-institut
mit der blick auf den verlauf der
virusvariante zeigt den rapiden anstieg
seit dem ersten nachgewiesenen fall in
deutschland alleine in der vergangenen
woche sind die omikron neuinfektionen um
mehr als 200 prozent gestiegen und auch
in dieser woche geht die tendenz steil
nach oben von dienstag auf mittwoch lag
der zuwachs bei 25 prozent und ein
mensch ist im zusammenhang mit omikron
gestorben mehr dazu von pablo seal
allein
deutschland kurz vor weihnachten die
omikron variante ist auf dem vormarsch
eine studie des renommierten imperial
college aus london macht jetzt hoffnung
omikron verläuft möglicherweise deutlich
milder als die delta variante laut
studie ging die zahl der
krankenhausaufenthalte um 20 bis 25
prozent zurück bei klinikaufenthalten
die länger als eine nacht dauern sogar
um 40 bis 45 prozent
christian drosten chefgeologe der
charité berlin spricht von einer
wegweisenden studie ungeimpfte haben bei
infektionen mit omikron versus delta
circa 24 prozent weniger risiko einer
krankenhausaufnahme um ikon ist also
gegenüber delta etwas abgeschwächt etwas
unterschied bei schweren verläufen
weiter unklar eine weitere britische
studie kommt zu ähnlichen ergebnissen
die korona modellieren pries man
mitglied des expertenrats der
bundesregierung warnt aber vor zu viel
optimismus
es gibt aus vielen verschiedenen
richtungen nachrichten die darauf
hinweisen dass der verlauf mit omikron
etwas milder sein könnte das ist ja
jetzt erst mal klasse die frage ist
immer wie viel angenommen das ist ein
faktor 2 melder dann ist es natürlich so
dass wenn dann die instanz wiederum
doppelt so hoch ist wie sie bisher war
das dann wieder genauso viele personen
die vorher vor dem krankenhaus hier
stehen also die schiere masse der
infizierten könnte zu übervollen
hospitälern führen wichtigstes mittel im
kampf gegen omikron das impfen ja wir
wissen dass ungewohnt deutlich
ansteckender ist auch seine vorläufer
dass es bleibt natürlich wichtig sich
impfen zu lassen es ist nach wie vor
wahrscheinlich dass auch eine infektion
omikron bei ungeimpften schwerer
verläufe erhoffen können wie hier in der
nähe von leipzig bleiben viele impf
stationen auch über die feiertage
geöffnet wenn die omikron welle kommt
will man gewappnet sein
die größer werdende omikron welle
schlägt sich noch nicht in den zahlen
nieder sie sinken weiter dem robert koch
institut wurden 44
1927 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
gemeldet
11.750 weniger als vor einer woche
425 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages hinzu die sieben tage incidents
sinkt nun auf zwei 180,3
die bundesregierung stuft die
urlaubsländer spanien und portugal ab
samstag als hochrisiko gebiete ein
ebenso die usa österreich wird dagegen
nach sechs wochen von der risikoliste
gestrichen wer aus einem hochrisiko
gebiet einreist und nicht vollständig
geimpft oder genesen ist muss für zehn
tage in quarantäne davon befreien kann
man sich frühestens fünf tage nach der
einreise mit einem negativen test
frankreich gilt ja schon seit ein paar
tagen als hochrisiko gebiet dort hat
sich am nikon schon weit ausgebreitet
die regierung rechnet damit dass die
variante schon nach weihnachten
vorherrschend sein wird im großraum
paris liegt der nachgewiesene omikron
anteil schon jetzt bei 35 prozent
manche experten nehmen an die variante
machen über 50 prozent der fälle aus die
sieben tage incidents schießt landesweit
seit wochen steil nach oben aus paris an
der hand sie arbeiten am limit in dieser
klinik in marseille gibt es noch genau
ein freies bett sie hat wie viele andere
in frankreich bereits in den krisen
modus umgeschaltet und nun kommt auch
noch omikron wir sind sehr besorgt da
diese variante so ansteckend ist das
bedeutet einerseits dass das
medizinische personal noch mehr
eingebunden wird aber auch dass kollegen
ausfallen könnten wenn sie sich
anstecken
schon in wenigen tagen könnte diese
variante im land vorherrschend sein die
gelassenheit mit der viele zuletzt dem
virus begegnet sind scheint passé in den
sozialen netzwerken mahnt der präsident
zur vorsicht beim weihnachtsfest
auch wenn sie geimpft sind lassen sie
sich testen damit sie sicher sind dass
sie das virus nicht auf ihre nächsten
übertragen
beim imf tempo zieht frankreich weiter
an bereits 20 millionen menschen haben
eine auffrischung erhalten auch kinder
werden nun geimpft und die regierung
will den druck auf ungeimpfte erhöhen
zugang nur mit test wäre dann an vielen
orten nicht mehr möglich so soll die
übertragung verhindert vor allem das
öffentliche leben aufrechterhalten
werden
auch wenn die meisten infizierten keine
oder kaum symptome zeigen sind sie
kontaktpersonen und können andere
anstecken diese arbeitsausfälle würden
sich massiv etwa auf den bereich der
dienstleistungen auswirken
100000 infektionen am tag lautet die
prognose für das jahresende die pandemie
stellt frankreich für eine neue
bewährungsprobe
was tun gegen das virus neben dem impfen
gibt es noch etwas auf dem die
hoffnungen ruhen nämlich medikamente neu
zugelassene tabletten könnten vor allem
bereits infizierten helfen und schwere
erkrankungen verhindern in den usa gibt
es die präparate per notfall zulassung
dazu jetzt claudia beck
diese pillen bringen hoffnung vor allem
für patienten die ein hohes risiko für
einen schweren corona verlauf haben wenn
erster symptome auftreten werden die
tabletten vom arzt verschrieben und
können über fünf tage zu hause
eingenommen werden jede behandlung
kostet in den usa rund 700 dollar weiter
sieht das medikament nicht als ersatz
sondern als ergänzung zur impfung über
die menschen müssen zunächst einmal
verhindern krank zu werden würden aber
nun könnten sie einen schweren verlauf
abwehren durch die tabletten aber sie
sollten sich vorsorglich schützen nicht
nur für sich sondern auch für die die
sie lieben
in den tests habe das medikament das
risiko von krankenhauseinweisungen und
tod um fast 90 prozent gesenkt so pfizer
für die intensivstationen wäre das ein
lichtblick der herstellungsprozess ist
allerdings komplex und dauert mehrere
monate auch eine tablette von merck
wurde heute in den usa zugelassen wie
bereits zuvor in großbritannien und
anderen ländern sie verhindert schwere
und tödliche verläufe zu 30 prozent
experten sehen in den tabletten eine
echte chance die pandemie unter
kontrolle zu bringen
wenn man diese tablette zusätzlich zur
impfung hat müssen nur noch sehr sehr
wenige menschen ins krankenhaus und wir
können wirklich langsam ganz aus der
pandemie herauskommen
hier in memphis werden die pfizer
tabletten gelagert die produktion soll
jetzt hochgefahren werden in den usa
stehen bereits im januar mehr als eine
viertel million dosen zur verfügung
gekauft hat die us-regierung bereits
zehn millionen dosen in europa läuft das
zulassungsverfahren noch deutsche
behörden verhandeln bereits mit dem
hersteller
diese proteste sind eine gezielte
konfrontation mit dem start das sagt der
münchner oberbürgermeister dieter reiter
über die sogenannten spaziergänge gegen
korona maßnahmen gestern abend haben
rund 5000 menschen unangemeldet ohne
masken und abstand demonstriert die
stimmung sei aggressiv gewesen so die
polizei beamte seien attackiert worden
pfefferspray und schlagstöcke wurden
eingesetzt und elf menschen vorläufig
festgenommen
außenministerin baerbock will besonders
schutzbedürftige menschen schneller aus
afghanistan evakuieren dazu soll es
weniger bürokratie bei der visa-vergabe
geben 15.000 menschen seien noch in
afghanistan deren aufnahme deutschland
zugesagt habe unter ihnen 135 deutsche
staatsangehörige seit der machtübernahme
der taliban seien mit hilfe der
bundesregierung rund 10.000 menschen
ausgereist
aus russischer perspektive zur
pressekonferenz des jahres heute
gewährte präsident putin wieder
hunderten journalisten mehr oder weniger
einblicke ins politische seelenleben des
landes der ablauf folgt einer strengen
kreml dramaturgie journalisten fragen
müssen vorher eingereicht werden die
themenliste entsprechend breit neben
viel innenpolitik ging es um die ukraine
die nato um gaspreise und corona
christian senn war dabei
warten auf putin der bekannte ist gerne
mal zu spät zu kommen
heute sind es 13
rund 500 journalistinnen und
journalisten kämpfen jetzt um seine
aufmerksamkeit mit ihren schildern und
hoffen dranzukommen dabei schwebt das
thema ukraine überall und der präsident
wiederholt russlands kernforderungen
es darf keine weitere nato
osterweiterung geben was ist daran so
schwer zu verstehen haben wie etwa
raketen in der nähe der amerikanischen
grenze stationiert nein die usa sind mit
ihren raketen bis vor unserer haustür
gekommen übrigens schon oma eine der
meist gestellten fragen dieser tage ist
ob es einen krieg gibt zwischen der
ukraine und russland putin betont zwar
dass russland kein krieg wolle aber
garantien will er auch nicht aussprechen
stattdessen worte eines gekränkten
präsidenten
[Musik]
sie haben uns in den 90ern gesagt kein
zentimeter richtung osten und dann
sie haben uns betrogen
es gab fünf wellen einer nato
erweiterung
putin lud sein land da noch für das
corona krisen-management das seit wochen
in russland jeden tag mehr als 1000
menschen wegen corona sterben spricht er
nicht an seine botschaft egal ob virus
oder nato russland bringt keiner zu fall
nach vier stunden hat wladimir putin
gesprochen zugeständnisse gab es keine
im gegenteil er bleibt dabei die nato
soll sich nicht richtung osten erweitern
und zusätzlich fordert er rasche
sicherheitsgarantien der usa im januar
soll es gespräche geben zwischen den usa
und russland in sachen ikra ihn und für
wladimir putin gibt's zum schlussapplaus
einiger russischer journalisten
von moskau nach hongkong dort war sie
ein wichtiges symbol für die demokratie
bewegung knapp 25 jahre erinnerte die
sogenannte säule der schande an das
massaker auf dem tiananmen-platz in
peking jetzt ist die skulptur entfernt
worden die chinesische regierung will
damit offenbar in der
sonderverwaltungszone das gedenken an
die opfer der proteste
1989 verhindern seit inkrafttreten des
umstrittenen nationalen sicherheits
gesetzes vergangenes jahr die behörden
hart gegen politisch andersdenkende in
hongkong vor
alle jahre wieder hunderttausende machen
sich auf den weg zur familie zu freunden
in diesem jahr wegen der pandemie wieder
unter heiklen bedingungen aber schon
alleine wegen der verabreichten
impfungen und der vergleichsweise
weniger harten kontakt beschränkungen
rechnet etwa die bahn dieses mal mit
mehr reisenden als im vorjahr
ferber
am düsseldorfer hauptbahnhof machen sie
sich auf den weg zu weihnachten hat die
bahn 100 zusätzliche züge eingesetzt
warten mit gepackten koffern und
gemischten gefühlen
und versucht sich glaube ich zu schützen
so gut wie man kann ich bin auf jeden
fall schon gewusst hat meine ganze
familie schuster testen uns also
im fernverkehr gibt es auch mehr
sitzplätze voll ist es teils trotzdem
auch am düsseldorfer flughafen gibt es
lange schlangen am check-in manche
fliegen in den urlaub die allermeisten
hier aber wollen zu familien ist mulmig
aber wir hoffen dass sie dass es mit der
ffp masken
abstellen dass es geht die lufthansa
musste einige transatlantikflüge absagen
zu viele piloten hatten sich
krankgemeldet unklar ob das mit corona
zusammenhängt im eigenen auto ist das
corona sicher aber nicht sicher der adac
rechnet mit mehr verkehr als im vorjahr
dabei gehe es nicht nur um die reise zur
familie die
auch skifahren ist in diesem jahr unter
bestimmten bedingungen wieder möglich
das heißt auch hier mit reiseverkehr
stattfinden wir gehen davon aus dass es
auch an den grenzen zu verzögerungen
kommen wird aufgrund der
stichprobenartigen kontrollen es reisen
wieder mehr menschen sie reisen in
pandemie zeiten sie reisen mit risiko
morgen ist heiligabend und viele feiern
den selbstverständlich in ihrem zuhause
nicht aber viele menschen aus dem ahrtal
nach der flutkatastrophe im juli die
hier 134 menschen in den tod riss haben
viele ihr heim verloren wie in der
rheinland pfälzischen stadt bernau in
der 90 prozent der häuser zerstört
wurden dort steht jetzt eine neue bleibe
für senioren damit sie weihnachten
wieder in ihrer heimat verbringen können
christopher hein silva da
seit wenigen tagen erst ist paula ist
zurück in ihrem heimatort dernau im
aartal die 88-jährige war mehrere monate
bei ihrem enkel untergebracht jetzt
bewohnt sie zusammen mit ihrem bruder
zwei container zimmer samt kleiner küche
und bad sind sie sehr froh dass sie
wieder hier sind ja ist heimat wenn man
hier geboren ist und je erlebt habe
waren 64 verheiratet
der mann starb ist noch wieder vor mir
ist
mitten in dernau stehen die
wohncontainer die anlage vom
arbeiter-samariter-bund mit vielen
details liebevoll hergerichtet
sozialarbeiterin kathrin zettel houston
betreut die 17 senioren hier sich selbst
kommt aus dem ort ist auch flut
geschädigte weiß also wie sich die
menschen fühlen wie hör mir mal so dass
sie froh sind jetzt angekommen zu sein
weil sie wissen das ist jetzt für eine
lange zeit dass sie hier sein dürfen und
sie freuen sich einfach dass sie hier
auch wieder gemeinschaft licht was
machen können wie ein gemeinschaftliches
mittagessen aber genauso dass sie auch
mit ihrer eigenen vier wände haben die
anlage soll so lange stehen bleiben wie
benötigt jetzt steht erstmal aber das
weihnachtsfest vor der tür
für paula hess und ihren bruder ist die
rückkehr in ihren heimatort wo das
größte weihnachtsgeschenk
wünschen schöne feiertage neues gibt's
aus der olympiastadt peking dort steigen
christin wieder die die korona sorgen
und olympia naht rückt immer näher 43
tage vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele sprechen die chinesischen
organisatoren ungewohnt deutlich über
die drohende gefahr durch die neue
virusvariante omikron es bestehe ein
hohes infektionsrisiko der druck sei
gewaltig
leere straßen in china nach ein paar
dutzend corona fällen ist die 13
millionen stadt in zentralchina im
lockdown tausend kilometer entfernt in
peking räumt der stellvertretende
direktor der abteilung für epidemie
bekämpfung beim olympia
organisationskomitee ungewohnt offen die
gefährdung 1
wir werden wahrscheinlich nur wenige
infektionen erleben das
übertragungsrisiko ist ziemlich hoch
aber darauf sind wir bestens vorbereitet
während den olympia-teilnehmern
inzwischen booster impfungen dringend
empfohlen werden sind die pläne für die
angedachte auslastung der hallen und
stadien mit zuschauern noch nicht im
detail bekannt
18 krankenhäuser in peking sollen denen
die mit olympia zu tun haben vorbehalten
bleiben zwei kliniken mit
englischsprachigen personal sind
offenbar im aufbau
in sechs wochen sollen die spiele
losgehen
zweiter weltcup slalom des olympia
winters und der endete erneut
enttäuschend für die deutschen
teilnehmer wieder keiner im zweiten
durchgang auch nicht linus straße der in
madonna di campiglio ausschied pech
hatte auch einer der favoriten
es ist das letzte tor das der franzose
klima nur verpasst ausgeschieden
rutschte er über die ziellinie der
derzeitige überflieger führte nach
seinem traumlauf in durchgang eins
souverän mit fast einer sekunde
vorsprung doch dann das drama im
zielbereich so kann der norweger
sebastian fußsohle war jubeln er gewinnt
den nachtslalom vor dem franzosen alexis
pinturault und dem schweden christoffer
jacobsen deutsche läufer spielen keine
rolle - strasser scheidet schon in
durchgang eins aus
neue chance fünfter ja nur ein skript
und worüber chancen redest danke
christine die chancen auf schnee und der
schnee machte weihnachten für viele
perfekt stehen im norden relativ gut
hamburg beispielsweise darf auf weiße
weihnachten hoffen schon heute konnten
rund um die landungsbrücken die ersten
kleinen schneemänner gebaut werden und
winterliche stimmung gab es für die
spaziergänger auch im osten von
schleswig holstein wie hier in eutin
wenn auch ein bisschen trübe ja so
sieht's aus die ausführliche weihnachts
wetterprognose mit glatteis mit schnee
und regen hat gleich katja horneffer
claus kleber meldet sich um 21 uhr 45
mit dem heute-journal und wir uns morgen
wieder an heiligabend pünktlich um 7
dann viel spaß bei den letzten
festvorbereitungen und noch einen
schönen donnerstagabend für sie
[Musik]
guten abend ob es bei ihnen für weiße
oder grüne weihnachten reicht machen
diese teams untereinander aus denn von
nordosten wird es kalt von südwesten
sehr mild heute nacht fällt schnee in
mecklenburg vorpommern und in
brandenburg und im laufe der nacht zieht
dieser schnee ostwärts ab aber es fällt
auch regen und der eben auf den
gefrorenen boden dann wird es
spiegelglatt machen sie sich also oft
lette gefasst hier von niederbayern bis
nach schleswig holstein im nordosten ist
es nur schnee die temperaturen liegen
dort knapp unter dem gefrierpunkt milder
bleibt die nacht im westen und morgen
erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen im
nordosten von nur so 12 grad plus sonst
wird es mild mit vier bis neun grad und
auch morgen regnet es erstmal noch
weiter das anfänglich gar nicht so viel
schnee dabei und es gibt auch eine
region wo es kaum regnet und zwar reicht
die hier vom vogtland bis hinüber
richtung eifel im norden fällt regen im
nordosten noch etwas schnee und da
bleibt es auch glatt beim starken bis
stürmischen wind aus nördlichen
richtungen
am ersten feiertag 10 schnee und regen
weiter nach süden wird es gefährlich
glatt hier in der mitte und im norden
strahlt die sonne über den neuschnee
flächen bei minus fünf grad und das tut
sie auch noch am zweiten feiertag
genannt